Shiva is the restaurant at baccarat
named after Joseph ie the designer of
many iconic pieces at baccarat who
brought back rod to a modern age at his
time in the 1920s 30s 40s and 50s I
think that what Barry star-like did by
purchasing this company is he brought it
to New York and brought it really to the
modern age by making black rock crystal
company into a lifestyle something that
can be enjoyed not just on special
occasions but every day therefore making
it very modern talk a little bit about
the artistry that is going into the
cuisine of Chevalier well it starts with
a very creative young chef he's made a
dish with white asparagus and pink
radishes it looks like a water collar
and I really believe that you eat with
your eyes first so when it's very
pleasing to the eye your next step is
you want to smell it and taste it and
that opens up your appetites you'll see
a lot of the dishes that che prepares
they're beautiful to look at but oh
they're absolutely astounding when you
when you taste them describe the
currently where we are in terms of
people's palette and sophistication and
what you roll you think Chevalier can
play I believe that the greatest of all
luxury is comfort people really value
their time more than anything else and I
believe that the mere fact of being able
to come into this restaurant at lunch
and perhaps choose one or two dishes
that are perfectly executed without
thinking oh god I should come here only
on special occasions
I think this marks the restaurant really
apart from other restaurants let's talk
about what they could dedicate to you
which I would imagine is like a sense of
understanding flowers I really believe
that when you bring flowers to someone's
home and in this case because you spend
a lot of time in a restaurant it becomes
your home it influences people in a very
subtle way sometimes you think well what
are they what are they here for it not
just embellishes the atmosphere but it
reminds you you're closing this to
nature as the nature changes you see
different flowers who the year
and this also reflects what we're about
to serve every day as the seasons change
is there a reappraisal that says yes the
chef chez gallant very important but not
the only ingredient to making something
work I believe that there is a
Renaissance in service knowing full well
that the full picture is not just what
the chef does or what we do in the
dining room there's a certain magic in
the air when the two get together and
perform what should be a memorable feast